foreign
[Music]
of the Finland Russia border whether we
see things like check posts watch Towers
fences enhanced borders more military
patrols more aerial overflight whatever
we're going to see we're going to see
develop in the coming months and years
as both Finland and Russia respond to
the changed nature of their own
relationship
finland's inclusion in the NATO alliance
is a strategic setback for Vladimir
Putin you invaded Ukraine apparently
over this fear of the expansion of NATO
well you've got the expansion of NATO on
your doorstep
the best the Russian military can do is
to hold on to its flailing war effort
inside of Ukraine uh whilst also taking
note of the fact that there is a lot of
NATO activity all along its border all
the way from the new member Finland in
the north down to existing members like
Romania and Poland further south nearer
the Black Sea this is an enormous amount
of space that the Russian Armed Forces
stretched in Ukraine are now going to
have to remain watchful of around the
buildup of NATO forces
[Applause]
it's clearly a very bad thing that a
country like Finland is that countries
are previously neutral are having to
pick a very ugly aside in what is likely
to be generational standoff between the
military Alliance and Russia if not
something that becomes even more
dangerous and years to come
okay